it was a cough cast experience  especially especially casting the Fable  men's because I was casting this based  on people I knew pretty well the first  difficult thing was deciding to tell the  story in the first place that was  probably the the hardest challenge in in  the sense that this is my private life  and I leave a little bit of myself we  all do behind in everything we we  perform in or write or direct or produce  we leave a little of ourselves behind  and so all of my films I consider to be  personal films but I've never really  made a movie that is about a uplift  experience as opposed to just a metaphor  to something else and so this was it  almost took the pandemic of having two  years literally nothing for me to have a  chance for Tony and I to get on Zoom and  talk about the feasibility of actually  telling the story of of a coming-of-age  story and it was also really wicked  weird to walk onto a set and actually  walk into my house from 1958.